90 degrees 90 degrees if I have a shape
that has 90-degree angles and all the
sides are the same length it's a square
yeah but wait you know as well as I do
if I go to the earth go on the earth and
say oh I'm going to start on the equator
go up to the North Pole then move over
90 degrees and take the line of
longitude down that goes right through
the Gulf of Mexico and Yucatan and hit
there oh I've got a 90 degree angle here
a 90 degree angle here and a 90 degree
angle here not a sphere I can have
triangles that have more than 180
degrees in them I can cut a piece of
paper on here that would be a
three-sided square I could sort of shape
this down here and here 90 degrees down
here it's not sure I do it correctly but
let's try this one each of the angles
here are 90 degrees here's a 90 degree
angle here's a 90 degree angle and
here's almost a 90 degree angle
here's a three-sided square all three
sides are the same length and all the
angles are 90 degrees let's hear not to
be confused with a ball but a sphere has
constant Gaussian curvature which says
that if I pick a point that point there
and draw two lines through it and choose
the maximum and the minimum curvatures
of those things multiply them together
positive number times a positive net
positive a sphere everywhere has
constant positive curvature okay neat
can I get something that has constant
negative curvature is it possible to
make something that is the opposite of a
sphere something that instead of always
bulging outward
if something that's always curving
inward can I make something and and and
the answer is yes I can make a pseudo
sphere a fake sphere it's funnel-shaped
it's Horan shaped and it has the
delicious property that if I pick any
point at all on it say right here in one
direction it'll bulge inward in the
other and the other direction it bulges
outward I have to make little little
point here that I have to pick the
minimum inward going in the and the
maximum outward going or the maximum is
either one of them I can't just rotate
this 90 degrees I have to or a few
degrees this way so it's like an X I
have to pick these so that in one
direction it's bulging out and the other
one it's bulging in turns out that a
pseudo sphere has everywhere constant
negative curvature that means that if I
multiply to get the Gaussian curvature
here where the positive going here is
not very big but the negative going is
huge and over here the positive the
negative going curvature is kind of
small but the positive curvature along
here is quite big a pseudo sphere
everywhere has constant negative
curvature let me go back for a minute
breathe I'm an ordinary Euclidean piece
of paper every triangle if I sum the
angles
I'll get 180 degrees on a sphere if I
draw a triangle any triangle at all I
draw on it the sum of the three angles
will be always greater than 180 degrees
it's true on the globe
true on a sphere on a pseudo sphere no
matter how I draw a triangle its angles
will always sum to less than 180 degrees
they'll be pointy in an odd way they'll
come to little pointy shapes we can take
advantage of that to draw
a shape that has 90-degree corners in
five sides
origami Asst Bob Lang showed me how to
do this from paper that he wrote and
uses all sorts of hyperbolic secant and
cosecant sand and hyperbolic functions
abound on this surface but the cool
thing is you can take a piece of paper
get it wet wrap it around here
everywhere has negative Gaussian
curvature by choosing my points just
just right I can find that eat here's a
five sided figure one two three four
five sides each of the corners is 90
degrees 90 there 90 there I did it okay
check keep me honest here let's take a
piece of paper that's ninety degrees
right there's a here's a 90 degree angle
right there right there yep ninety
degree angle there over here
sure enough 90 degrees 90 degrees 90 90
here's a five sided figure the five
catches a five sided figure all corners
are ninety degrees let's say and cut out
a paper like this here is say here's the
piece of paper folded to fit shaped to
fit on top the pseudo sphere each of
these corners are ninety degrees it's a
Pentagon it's a Pentagon whose corners
are all ninety degrees if I say hey a
square is a shape that has equal side
equal length edges in all corners are
ninety degrees then I could claim that
this is a five sided square so it's
edges are equal lengths as well each of
those edges is the same
what happens if I bash it flat well a
nifty thing about topology says it
shouldn't be possible if I try bashing
this flat it's like taking a section of
a sphere taking a section of the globe
in bashing it flat there's not a good
mapping that will preserve areas that
will preserve directions we get into the
problem of conformal mapping and non
conformal mapping and things like this
we can do this but as I push down here
that bends out push down here oh I'll
just bend over here oh maybe if I push
down here oh then it bumps up here bumps
up there I know how about if I push this
one in this one down this one this one
this I've got five fingers one two three
one two three four five and up but now
it's bumping up here I can sort of put
it in a press but it's trying to pop out
the bottom of the table you can't
perfectly map a spherical or a pseudo
spherical surface onto a Euclidean plane
it's a problem that map makers have had
for a long time and it's a problem that
shows up when you start mapping your
universe because our universe apparently
seems to have something of negative
curvature now thanks to the great
courses plus for supporting this video
if there's anything you want to learn
about including mathematics the great
courses plus is gonna have it have a
look at this one it's called crazy kinds
of connectedness but it's not just
mathematics pretty much anything you
want to learn about they're gonna have
loads on it for example mountaineering
is something I'm interested in they've
got you covered there or how about dog
training this is a 24 part course on dog
training which I find fascinating and I
especially love because have a look Lulu
this dog here is called Lulu my dogs
called Lulu but it's not all about dog
training seriously you name it they've
got it and it's going to be taught by
world-class experts from institutions
and universities all across the globe
now if you go to the great courses plus
comm slash numberphile there's also a
link in the description you can check it
out and do a free trial access to
everything I think it's something like
10,000 videos you've got it
our thanks to the great courses plus for
supporting this video